that's who he is you know and I follow
them a bit when he was at Oklahoma when
he had the signs and you know the flag
thing oh you like you know I followed
all that stuff and again the
walkie-talkie you know and he definitely
has that attitude and charisma and you
know that is contagious Jarvis Landry
Browns receiver and quickly the favorite
target of new quarterback Baker Mayfield
Landry also said yesterday that he can
make every throw make every read do
everything necessary and this is a guy
who got thrust into it last week how
much better could he be Chris with time
to actually prepare he had no prep no
first team reps came in and got it done
now he's had three extra days to get
ready for this game at Oakland what do
you expect from it I expect I expect to
see some good things I really do I mean
do I think he'll have a few mistakes
here and there yeah of course he's a
rookie but I think also would this week
like you're saying he gets reps he gets
to do those things but more importantly
the offensive coordinator gets to
formulate some things around him to go
oh I know you like this or I wanted to
do this in these offense but tie-rod
wasn't a big fan of doing it so now they
can do things that they really feel like
Baker Mayfield can take advantage of
with his you know what you saw last week
top level ability to throw the football
around the field I mean he's a natural
gifted thrower of the football I mean
you saw that right Mike I mean when he
for those first few throws down the
field the ball just pops out of his
hands and I think you're gonna see Mike
like with Todd heylia's zlc a little
blend of Pittsburgh Big Ben just get him
in the shotgun and let you dice let him
dice you up but I think they'll stay a
little bit more consistent with the run
game too and maybe get him on the move
and play actions and boots because that
is something Big Ben can't do quite as
well as a Baker Mayfield you know we
didn't see the Jets too much last
Thursday night to stymie Baker Mayfield
what kind of things can the Raiders do
with the benefit of seeing him play
against the Jets to try to maybe counter
him and take away the things we saw him
do well yeah I think the the big thing
is that they're not gonna totally know
all the things he does
well or doesn't do well yet I don't know
if there's enough video evidence but to
me my big my big point would be it's a
rookie quarterback making his second
their first start and it's on the road I
would never want him to feel comfortable
disguising coverages and changing up
looks to me would be the number one
thing I would want to do for the Oakland
Raiders defense because yeah he's got
enough to worry about it's a new
experience he's got coached to
quarterback communications he's trying
to tell people the line of scrimmage and
oh I've studied this defense and they
play this coverage all week when we get
in this formation well bomb the Raiders
I'm trying to make things not look
normal or disguise as best as I can or
change the coverage late into the snap
count do things like that to where you
make him second-guess himself a little
bit to where he can't just stand in
there like we saw last week
get the ball find a guy and rifle it
through a window yeah and it really was
amazing to see it all happen that
quickly and I think to a certain extent
you know the adrenaline the excitement
that you know is that something that you
can recreate on the road that's what's
going to be difficult right we all felt
that when he came onto the field after
Tyrod Taylor got injured and it felt
like it was going to be a special night
from the moment it all started very
different vibe when you go out to
Oakland and you're facing a team that is
desperate to get a win I you know I look
if and III don't want to be on the wrong
side of this if it goes the way that I
think it could always what you think
that's gonna go I mean I think well
remember TiVo mania in 2011 and that was
a guy who couldn't throw the ball I mean
this is a guy who was showing up and
he's getting it done and it's exciting
and and you know for whatever reason and
I don't know how much the NFL planned to
do this but it's worked perfectly
between Hard Knocks with the Browns
between what three or four it felt like
every preseason game they had was in a
national TV window so we became more
interested in the Browns and that Baker
Mayfield dynamic hovering over the team
four years after Johnny Manziel and it's
that same you know the excitement of
brash young quarterback who can come in
and remember how Mayfield bristled at
the comparisons of Johnny Manziel yeah
and it all is just lining up
for Mayfield - and the guy who has had
who has had as you would say a high
degree of self-confidence in himself a
guy who you know everywhere he went when
he when he walked on a Texas Tech he
becomes the starter he transfers to
Oklahoma becomes the starter and he's
constantly doubted and he constantly
proves the doubters wrong and there is
something very real about that it's
intangible but it's also very real and
we saw it and and I I think come Monday
we're gonna be saying well we should
have realized that this is Baker
Mayfield I mean these aren't the same
old Browns and this is a different kind
of a guy and this is why there were so
many teams out there that we're quietly
lurking waiting for a chance to get to
Baker Mayfield because this guy I talked
to somebody this week that was on that
short list of teams that was trying to
scheme and connive a way to maybe get
Baker Mayfield it's like hey it's
exactly what we thought he was gonna do
did what we thought he was gonna do and
now we've seen he can do it and now the
question is how many more times is he
gonna do it and how good can he be yeah
he's that good with no prep how good's
he gonna be once he's been playing once
he's been preparing and once he develops
even more confidence yeah I mean I'm
excited to see it I certainly am I mean
the Cleveland Browns will be the more
talented team on the field on Sunday in
Oakland they will be but like you said
the Raiders are a desperate team and
going back to Mayfield yeah Mayfield is
the better throwing polished version
version of a Johnny Manziel that's what
he is he said way he's a way more gifted
thrower the football and he's way more
professional and buttoned up than a
Johnny Manziel that's probably why he
bristled at that comparison back then it
wasn't fair to him why just because he
was short and played like a free willing
type of football Mike I did a game of
Baker Mayfield when he was at Texas Tech
but I was just getting into this whole
crazy business and I was working for Fox
Sports 1 and I know I'm not trying to
like talk talk myself up here but it was
one of those things where when I was on
field and warm-ups and would watch him
to different games I did that year of
Texas Tech I was like wow this kids a
gifted thrower like I don't know what
Kliff Kingsbury is look at that this
needs to be the starter this needs to be
the guy and he was still going back
between him and Webb and then of course
Patrick mahomes came to the equation and
he goes to Oklahoma and just tears it up
but
he's got some moxie about them and he
just has a Swagger and a confidence that
you can see is contagious to the rest of
the team oh how you like that not bad
but I look I I think that that it's
consistent with everything we've seen
from Baker Mayfield and the question was
would it work at this level because with
Johnny Manziel everything that he could
do everything that was magical about him
at the college level didn't translate a
large part because he wasn't willing to
put in the work
Mayfield's got those intangibles and
he's willing to put in the work he's
willing to do what needs to be done and
so far he's done it when he's had the
chance and yeah I really do have a
feeling he's gonna be making your buddy
Jon Gruden really really upset on Sunday
afternoon
you